today's episode is brought to you by oh
we're aware is one of the largest
studies ever conducted that's trying to
understand the relationship between mood
and PTSD so veterans and their families
can live healthier and happier lives
aware is sponsored by the US Department
of Veteran Affairs and overlap health
it's a health technology company making
health care better for everyone what's
awesome about this study it's 28 days
long you don't have to have PTSD or even
be a veteran they're encouraging
everyone to join you just got to be over
the age of 18 live in the u.s. and speak
some English this is an opportunity for
you you just download the aware study
from the app or play store fill out some
baseline questions and just follow the
instructions in the app and in a couple
minutes per day that's it a couple
minutes per day you'll see your mood
change over the month and you'll get
tools to help you in the moment when
you're feeling a little sad or a little
down just go to a we're study org and
download on iOS or Android today and
that's it man aware they just want to
make you aware of how you're feeling and
what's going on it's a study that's it
go be a part of it help help learn about
PTSD help help them learn the US
Department of Veteran Affairs and
overlap health that's exciting and that
is a where study org download on iOS or
Android today oh man I just give myself
a frickin bad haircut you ever cut your
own hair probably not because if you did
those listeners will probably be 7 11 12
14 years old sometimes that still flares
up in me though you know I'll be in the
bathroom or something at the house or
all and I do [ __ ] when I'm running late
something's wrong with me I will
literally I will be running late for
something you know I got 30 seconds till
I got to be downstairs and I'll see a
pair of scissors and I'll remember oh I
got one stray hair on the sideburn or
something or I got an ear that's trying
to you know trying to grow up you know I
got a ear
that's trying to start sharecropping
some hair of its own and I'll start just
I'll give myself a damn haircut and then
I'll be and look I've done it I've done
it in my lifetime probably a hundred to
probably 300 times and every time it's
bad
every time the haircut that I give
myself in a hurry is bad but I continue
to do it every time the idea pops in my
head it's like it's the first time it
popped in and it could be good that's
how it breaks down inside of my head
something is wrong with me what is wrong
with me I don't know maybe nothing maybe
everything's okay and this is just who I
am
I don't know we're about to find out
about all of this welcome to this past
weekend
[Music]
this Monday baby or is it this is a
great big world waiting right outside
man it sounds good huh Mary's my boy we
people have that true
mother my hair is my head
[Music]
the why didn't I try my mother may have
slipped away though I did my damn back
hmm
that's powerful you can come for me mmm
I'm gonna keep riding this one for a
second guys I'm in this I'm in here
[Music]
[Laughter]
you can't comfort me
you
[Music]
you do I do have your May
stuck in my ear and down the plane come
on man come on oh my plea hmm though I
beg you let me be the devil you ignore
my plea man I didn't expect to go into
that song that long but that boy's voice
is thick isn't it that boy got that man
and you can hear in his voice I hear it
all in his voice sometimes people have a
special gift in them and they have just
that voice and you hear just the whole
world inside of their man in that boy's
voice right there that is Evan Bartles
or Evan bartels Evan Bartles I bet it's
Bartles that is Evan Bartles and we're
gonna put a link to that song and that
is the devil God and me and so you can
go listen to that it's on youtube and
we'll put some other links to it right
here on our on on everything evan
Bartels man huh you know there's a lot
of beautiful music out there and uh but
that boy's got something in him you know
when i hear is when i hear and i wonder
what it is about singing because it's
him it's this man it's this singer this
musician of course he's May he's he's
singing the song and the words are
strong you know
you know the words and it's just a
perfect mix that's what it is there's
moments where something is just a
perfect mix and for that friend you know
some people might not if you don't like
this kind of is a thing you're like well
uh can you hurry on and get on to
something else Theo but I like I mean I
just you know this is he's just talking
about things talking about Kenny can he
sip the wine if he didn't end the vine
you know talking about his mother if his
mother if he's allowed to speak up if
he's allowed to use his voice you know
just different things and I mean just
the other thing gets me man the devil
God and me by Evan Bartles and we'll put
the links to that oh man what's going on
there's just that perfect man in that
boy's voice you could hear it all I
could hear a wagon coming across a
Prairie you know I could hear a fire I
could hear a fire going you know I could
hear a homeless man I could see Adam and
Eve looking up at the sky and witnessing
the Big Bang I could see at all you know
I could see a shooting star could see a
mountain erode I could see a ocean just
tackle a [ __ ] universe I could see it
all like I see a couple crickets [ __ ]
in that boy's voice I could just see it
it just like the whole I could see it
that whole timeline of everything you
know I could see the sands just covering
up civilizations
you know just strong wind picking up in
the sand I mean the desert just needs
one strong whip a wind and it can hide a
whole civilizations just from one of
just mother nature gut just you know cut
a strong wind across the desert you know
mother nature does you know bust a
strong fire and next thing you know the
desert has shifted all of its granules
and covered up a whole civilization we
live in a powerful world man we forget
that I forget it I don't say we forget
it I don't know what you do but I forget
it sometimes I forget that man I live in
a power
I'm just uh I'm just a damn I'm just a
meandering
I'm just a meandering problem I'm just a
meandering a problem maker illness a
beautiful science experiment
out here in the middle of nowhere and
every now and then it's hard for me to
capture the whole universe of everything
that's going on into one moment but then
sometimes that's the gift of music then
for me is that sometimes a voice and a
moment and some lyrics and stuff come
along and they put it together right for
me you know that boy did it he did it
right there and that is uh that's the
devil God in me by having Bartles thank
you for being here thank you for
spending some time with me cutting me on
and whatever if you're driving around in
that Honda Civic or whatever you got
that Toyota Tercel baby you know I'm
saying you and Charlene shout they're
stunting you know y'all might be have a
little bit of sweat under y'all's
breasts but y'all
yeah it ain't me nuttin you know I'm
saying that's just summertime that's the
summertime causing a little bit of body
ski that's nothing boo that I mean y'all
can't pull over and [ __ ] split a
Butterfinger you feel me do my mom used
to get we should my mother had a Ford
Fiesta growing up and I don't have you
ever seen that car you might not have
seen it because it's only about six and
a half feet long so you could be looking
around and not even really see it it
almost looks like a dude I remember one
time we pulled up next to a dumpster to
put throw some stuff in it and the
dumpster was bigger than bigger than the
whole car like dang on this car small
it's called real real small it look like
a pregnant roller skate it look like a
roller skate had been [ __ ] by a couple
of you know uh you know maybe a couple
of not a couple but a doc Martin look
like a doc Martin had [ __ ] the roller
skate and then but they hadn't gotten
along and then the roller skate moved to
see
have the baby by itself and then it gave
birth to the Ford Fiesta I think that
was at Fort fear forward what was a my
mom had a Ford small Ford car Ford
Fiesta
yeah it must have been a Ford Fiesta
bruh that thing was nothing fusion
Mustang Fiesta I don't know man Fiesta
sounds too fancy what else dude
Ford Fiesta it must have been a fiesta
but it was the kind of car mom could
beat my mom it was she so mom would
drive we have four children you know and
my brother and he was pretty browned up
my brother my brother got a lot of the
Latino kind of coloring that was in our
blood and Native American that's what we
had in our blood and polish you know
we're about that polish power and then a
couple cuts of Italian because you can't
keep Italian out to anything you can't
keep Italian out any gene pool
start a gene pool somewhere and look at
and walk away for a little bit and then
come back they'll have a couple of
Italians in there you know soaking their
legs
you can't keep Italian out of any gene
pool that's the strongest gene I think
you know as soon as they start soon
they're gonna be start coming out with
black Italians and it's a rap you can't
stop a black Italian there will be an
unstoppable community of humanity and
I'm excited for do that beautiful but
you have a beautiful black physique boy
that Italian be that wild Italian hair
Brooke come on dude I do [ __ ] just
straight-up Duncan he's got calzones
tattooed on his [ __ ] biceps cam and
that'd be beautiful what am I talking
about I don't know dude I've had [ __ ]
anxiety out the yangyang bro dude I've
had some anxiety recently and I mean I
might be eating some pitted cherries
during this because I picked me up a
little sack of cherries on the way here
man I love a damn cherry my daddy used
to eat cherries but I'll say this man I
forgot to tell you I was talking that
Ford Fiesta
because we had a Ford s Ford Escort but
my mother had a Ford Fiesta and the
beautiful thing about the Ford Fiesta
was you could beat somebody if you as
the parent or used the captain or the
driver you could beat somebody you know
no matter if he had four children we'd
all be in there you know my brother
skintone that's I was talking about so
he had yeah we had the four children and
my mom sheekha bam bam bam bam because
she did she would stretch in the morning
and my mom she could put that shoulder
straight back you know she was
double-jointed in her shoulders and that
helped to beat children and my mother
was you know she might have been
aggressive
I wouldn't call my mother an abuser I
don't she was physically abusive at
least for that period of time it wasn't
but man she will I mean like she was
playing the cymbals dude she [ __ ] hit
it flat off at daddy's forehead - my mom
cook whoop some is mine but that and
that was part of the day back then man
getting you ass whoop you I didn't think
you were a real child if you didn't get
you ass whoop if you never had your ass
whooped came out were you really a child
think about it your mother never whooped
you come on are your daddy never whooped
you I don't know I don't know man dude I
uh B I grew up with a lot I just had
someone saying society man everything
man you know I don't talk about anxiety
that much and I think because some of my
anxiety is going away from once I got an
a a program or I started finding
recovery for myself or seeking out forms
to make myself feel better but dude I
had a I had anxiousness as a child I had
anxiety and I think part of the reason I
had so much anxiety as a child was
because I was I was breastfed on a cups
my mother had them baby A's
you know when it came when it came time
for you know on them tea toss my mom had
them at coops you know then maybe a cups
and for a baby when you try to
breastfeed when you were when you're a
baby in your breastfeeding I don't know
if there's anything more anxious looking
then a baby trying to breastfeed off of
a cup because you're trying to get all
that let's say you know you're trying to
hit that you know just straight-up catch
that that DNA you know that DNA uh you
know you're trying to catch that just
jowl up with that milky milky offset and
you can't get enough you can't get it
you're trying to rattle that milk out of
a little a cup come on and that's today
and that's just you know as a baby
you're just trying to rattle that a cup
but Dean I don't care how much you
rattle there ain't enough during them
there ain't much you know there ain't
much sauce in that in that dish if your
mom got them small breasts and look I
love my mother you know and I'm not a
discredit in her my saying there's
anything wrong with my mother at all I
respect my mother's body it was
beautiful body you know my mother's
always taking care of her body and I've
always thought that my mother was a
beautiful woman but damn boy when you're
a child and you got a rattle you trying
to rattle some milk out of an a-cup you
know that's like trying to beat a couple
sips of you know a punch out of a out of
an empty a Capri Sun sank can can you do
it and that rattle what I'm saying is
that rattle as a baby that rattle never
leaves your body that shaking shaking
shaking rattling just you know beating
your hands against a small a cup breast
trying to get a sip of you know that
body guava that never leaves you
and so I know joke I have a theory that
a lot of my anxiety and a lot of anxiety
out there comes from children who were
raised and breastfed off them small a
cup breasts because you never forget
that just that constant judge but
nothing very little in there maybe you
catch a drop you know when your mom
leans over to look at some maybe you
catch you know a quarter Grammy in the
back of your throat but very little in
the makeups
very very little
in that rattle that desperation never
really leaves you the uncomfort because
as a baby you're really putting yourself
out there when you think about it when
you're sucking on a breast or a you know
a teddy you know some people call them
Teddy's especially like if you're in
Scotland and like I look at it look at
the teddy asana you know if you if you
are you know you know if you're gumming
up on a breast or a teat or a teddy
then you you're putting yourself out
there you know as a baby you know as a
baby you're putting yourself out there
man because you know other babies might
be around there might be relaxing maybe
the dog is in the room maybe your dad's
in the room or a sibling and you're
gonna just try it you're gonna I mean
you're not it's not like you're waiting
by our microwave you're sucking on that
heater when you're breastfeeding as a
baby you know I'm saying you're just
putting your face and just taking all
the chances and that's exposing yourself
that's putting yourself out there just
giving his sucking to stay alive and the
fact that nothing might come out and
that's embarrassing then people got to
look around and see your cheeks ain't
filling up and I think I went through a
lot of that you know and my brother had
also gotten to my mother's breast before
me he was older than me and he was born
before me and he breastfed before me and
I even remember one time when I even and
I vaguely vaguely remember this and some
of this memory is more in my bones than
it is in my brain but I vaguely remember
there being my brother elbowing me off
that breast you know I'm just kidding
you know just giving me that sharp you
know just that arm edge that elbow you
know just giving me that [ __ ] rep
that that natural right angle of the arm
that elbow and just you know nudging me
off that two-top nudging me right off
Mama's tuck top and taking that you know
maybe catching a couple you know
whatever last gram
the milk was in there and leaving me off
that leche and that's it's just toughen
so I think a lot of my anxiety started
then a lot of my anxiety started then
and some people you know like you may
you know and it makes sense it just
makes such sense the struggle because
here's the other thing the other babies
was these fatty fatty babies and they
over there with a long eyelashes because
they got a lot of milk in them and the
milk is making you know parts of their
body grow and they got strong bones and
they got [ __ ] eat you know they might
have an ankle weighs it you know each
one of their ankles now weighs a couple
ounces probably because they're boning
up their bodies marrow and up because
they converting that milk and they
looking all fat and unconscious one baby
had passed out and a lot of milk had
ruled out of his mouth and pulled up
around his eye he had that naughty white
eye patch you know that fat baby [ __ ]
eye patch when it that milk you know
they're they're sleeping at such an
angle where the milk rolls out of their
mouths and just pulls up in their eye
around their eye on top of their closed
eyelid and they got that [ __ ] leche
eye patch you know and you're like Dan
that fat [ __ ] he have so much milk
over by him he [ __ ] he doing just
tricks with it he's doing with stunts
this [ __ ] over here David Blaine
and under his [ __ ] milk sleeping
under half an ounce and I'm out here
judge just fighting for every damn drip
at a drap drought
I'm just saying that is the struggle
when your mother got a small breast and
you trying to get that natural that
natural body sauce off out it you trying
to get that you know that there are that
nurture that you trying to get fed and
that anxiety never leaves you oh sorry I
went off on that but that [ __ ] bends me
up a little bit because I think about
anxiety I think about how anxiety gets
baked in you as a child here's another
thing I think if you were a
of children you get anxiety because you
were conceived in a doggy style position
and a lot of people think that's crazy
and sorry I'm having a little bit what I
got up me a sack of cherries hmm and
they're good I think these are from
Washington State oh we're actually
Montana dude everybody say different
people have cherries and stuff go to
Montana then get you a sack of them
[ __ ] hitters boy
mother nature's g-spots right here boy
these Bing cherries come out my daddy
used to eat these at night and let me
hold the pits in my hand if I was
well-behaved but anyhow I was like I'm
out oh I think babies that were
conceived in the doggy style position
come out with severe anxiety because
that's pressure imagine you have of
course if you're conceived in doggy
style you feel like you got to put on a
show for the world and that's baked into
you whereas if you just say you know if
you just that casual just loitering just
missionary baby and you come out all
just loitering into the world just had
me scenario then yeah you're gonna have
a casual lifestyle but if you that that
that naughty daughter that pops out of a
doggy style conception Cameroon you
gonna be a tricky [ __ ] out in the world
cuz you're gonna be nervous because you
already feel like you have to put on a
show before you've even opened your eyes
or your soul to the world so it's crazy
how many things can happen how many
things can be baked into us that we
don't even realize you know how many
things can be that are just beyond us
you know and I say I guess some of this
stuff I've had a wild week man I'm going
to Nashville I'm flying to Nashville in
a couple of hours I'm so yeah I'm so
stoked dude I can't can I tell you guys
I guess I could tell you I don't know I
I'm flying to Nashville in a few hours
[ __ ] now keeping a secret but it's okay
I think it's a fun secret so to be cool
I'm flying to Nashville in a few hours
and
I yeah and then I hit well here's what
happens so I had I went to therapy man
you know what to therapy the other day
and I go to therapy and also when I want
to tell you right now actually and this
is a great time and tell you this
actually because I test it I tested out
this company and this company is called
better help calm and this is look listen
to this you know listen to a lot of ads
that's fine you don't want to listen to
advertisements that's fine but this
isn't an advert I mean this is this is a
company this is an opportunity I see it
this is professional and affordable
counseling just for mental health you
can get masked with the counselor who's
right for you I just did this you know
they sent me this opportunity and I was
like well let me check it out first so I
checked it out and I had two sessions
with this lady named Anna and one of
them was over the phone and one of them
was over Skype and it was good man it
was good it was good counseling you get
matched with the counselor who's right
for you there are four communication
modes text chat phone and video that's
everything unless you want to mail each
other a diorama or something you can
start communicating in there under 24
hours you must be 18 years old it's
available worldwide better help calm
slash Theo th e oh that's better help
calm slash Theo it's proactive mental
health this isn't a crisis line this
isn't a Christ this isn't you know you
about to jump off a building don't call
these people call somebody else call
your boy with a ladder call the you know
call the 9-1-1 but this is available on
desktop mobile Android and iOS and it's
a therapist it's counseling this is a
chance you never spoken to a counselor
[ __ ] try it out or if you have and
the one you have didn't work or you're
in a small place small town in their
zone you're afraid to talk somebody look
talk to somebody you know my life all
got better when I started talking to
someone it really did and that's better
help calm slash Theo th EO
check it out if you want to and I say
because I checked it out I checked it
out and it was good and I'm probably
gonna continue some of my sessions you
know I see a therapist in real life and
but this was also this is just a
different way and it cuz you don't
here's the things to know you don't know
how things are gonna react to you you
know some people like to be chefs and
some people just like to eat some people
like to just [ __ ] walk through the
supermarket and look at ingredients and
then starve to death
people relate to things different ways
and we use things different ways and so
if you don't have access to a therapist
or the a therapist in person didn't work
for you try this out better help calm
slash Theo th EO and check it out what
else and we have our hotline you can
always call nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and and that's not
a that's also not a line or if you
jumping off a building that's just line
if you want to be part of the show you
want to communicate about what we're
talking about or or or anything you can
let us know
you also can leave videos online on our
we have the fan line link if you want to
leave a if you want to send in a video
that can be part of our show send it in
it's through the live raise you can send
it in and we'll make it and we'll make
some of those part of the show and we'll
put that link as well that's a live
raise for video questions submissions
and you can see those on YouTube as well
what else is going on man Oh solvent got
therapy man you know and uh dude I
remember first time I got therapy I was
twenty-two you know and I hitchhiked up
there to South Carolina to Charleston
and I found myself on my ex-girlfriends
porch petting somebody's cat and I
didn't know whose cat it was and and I
didn't really know who I was and so the
next day I said [ __ ] I gotta get some I
gotta go see mental health therapists
because this isn't right you know you
don't hitchhike that far to go you know
touch a little bit of pus but but you
don't know whose it is and it's on
somebody's porch and it's an animal and
so I had to tighten up I had a G up and
that's the first time I ever went to see
a mental health there
and this isn't part of the better help
thing anymore I'm not talking about that
I'm just talking about my own life but I
went this past this past week to talk
and uh man it just you know I still got
a lot of work to do on myself and that's
okay it doesn't mean I'm gonna be hard
on myself all the time and I'm not gonna
enjoy myself I went to the beach this
morning dude you know one of the I mean
I went out there to a meeting but one of
the cool things about Los Angeles is
they have these cool meetings you can go
to and sometimes they're in unique
places and this one was on the beach so
I'm out there in this kind of self-help
group everybody's sitting up there
listening to each other and bullshitting
you know and that a couple of straight
up lurkers out there I think honestly
peaking over at my shoulders and looking
at my you know cuz I got nice nice
shoulders and I've always had I think
honestly you know some of the nicest
clavicles in town boy I got that [ __ ]
baby back you know my clavicles look
[ __ ] sexy like a couple of baby back
ribs snuck away up by my neck and I've
always had nice clavicles and I even
remember when I would take my shirt off
as a child by the pool and some of the
female camp counselors would just be
like damn look at the Vics on that boy
cuz I got them [ __ ] clavicles you
know I'm not I'm not
upper skeletal Ashkelon bad boy you know
I'm that [ __ ] Puff Daddy
of Clavis you feel me I break them
things out people like we ain't go in
nowhere we ain't mMmmm we lookin at his
bones he bad bones for life I got them
up top hitters you know and you got to
find out what features of yours are nice
you know but anyway I was out I was out
at that meeting and then afterwards and
I'm out of the beach and I went in the
water and there's something dude there's
it there is something I'll say and look
I've been in the ocean three times in
the past three weeks and and it's
feeling good I'm feeling real grateful
you know I was thinking about I was
thinking about
and let me know how this episode is let
me know if this episode is any different
than other episodes if anybody noticed
something because I'm recording this
episode way earlier in the day than I
usually do so I'm starting to wonder if
there's a time of day where I'm just can
be more in tune with what's going on and
King you know just communicate better
but anyhow I got out in that water dude
I was thinking about this so you know
we've been talking a lot recently or you
know we've been talking a lot recently
about like you know if you pass away
after life and that kind of thing and
that's been milling around and uh and
I'm thinking that
so we're I'm not I've already talked
about this we're 90% water or seventy
eight percent or ninety eight percent or
something whatever dude all I'm saying
is that we got a lot of water in us a
lot and the cool thing about water is if
you just look at water and how it works
in our ecosystem here on earth and our
you know from our solar system down to
our ecosystem you know it come you know
water comes in from the clouds
precipitation it falls down if it gets
some of it evaporates back up and
sometimes it comes back down some of it
joins a part of something real cool like
a river or a lake or um a birdbath do it
a lot of lakes act like they're - [ __ ]
how about a [ __ ] birdbath dog you
know I'm saying that front yard baby
lake that is the real that's that real
you know bad boy body of water is that
birdbath boy that [ __ ] stationary
aviary [ __ ] wash up because a
birdbath it's like hey I'm a lake I'm a
[ __ ] on a pedestal other lakes you
know they gotta be over here and they
got fish in them and [ __ ] bird baths
like hi I'm up here I'm I'm lifted up
I'm up in this little stone piece I'm
set into this dealio man a birdbath that
thing flexes
and then here's the thing about a
birdbath it's got birds stopping by
what other coming other lakes a lot of
lakes and stuff birds pass by steal a
fish you ever see that [ __ ] you ever see
a bird just steal a fish from a lake and
a lake can't do anything a lake don't
have a lot of weapons because the weapon
was rain that's really its weapon and
then that's a lake is just the aftermath
of water weaponry and damn a bird come
through and just [ __ ] steal your fish
boy and I'll Lake can't just throw a
[ __ ] wave up and slap a bird out so I
think lakes need more training
maybe lakes could do some Brazilian
jiu-jitsu or something but a birdbath
dude that's that [ __ ] you know that's
just like a dam you know that's this
that beautiful little spectacle you know
it's just that uplifted teardrop a
birdbath dam that's the elite that's the
elite of local watery
water ari water whatever water stuff
water Ness you know what I'm saying if I
can I'm talking about did I gotta quit
going off on tangents oh but I got out
in the water and here's what I was
thinking about us about life so we're
98% water or something or we're 98.6
degrees or something and we're you know
we're also in sync and boys to men and
the Backstreet Boys and we are don't go
chasing waterfalls anyway we're made out
of a lot of water and water the water
does water is part of this beautiful
cycle and so that's what I'm thinking
man we have to be part of a beautiful
cycle the clue is the water think about
how much water is in you dude if you get
sad water comes out of your [ __ ] eyes
bruh have you ever thought about that
when you get sad water it's like ah man
I ain't hanging out in here anymore
this [ __ ] said I'm getting out
of this [ __ ] and water starts
looking for somewhere else to be that's
why you got to stay happy man you got to
make your water happy and keep your
water
cuz happy water stays in you it Mills
around it helps you out you know it
helps process things in your body and
keep you feeling good and keep your
mouth wet but once you start getting all
sad and baldy baldy
you know no I didn't do you know he took
he took half my Butterfinger and he you
know and in the government day you know
and I didn't you once you start blaming
others and crying and whining that's
when your waters like I'm out of here
I'm leaving your body because you've
been there and I'm gonna find somewhere
else more magical to be and that's what
happens but the beautiful thing about
water is is part of that cycle and we're
so much made of water it'd be hard to
believe that we're not part of a really
cool cycle we come down here onto the
planet we get to do cool stuff
sometimes you're part of something neat
sometimes you're part of not something
neat and then you get brought back up
into a higher being into the world and
the clouds into a heaven into a
beautiful place and then you come back
down and you out here just getting
washed through through the system that's
a dude there and that's it might take a
little bit of imagination the others not
any science to prove that but dude one
[ __ ] big whoosh of a wave or one big
of a you know of a shooting star hits us
and all y'all science ain't [ __ ] anyway
I mean science just came out of an idea
so what I'm saying is this the idea
could be that we get stuck in that
wearing that you're a part of that water
you dye your water goes back into the
earth starts a plant sometimes you
planta water gets caught on a leaf the
rain will come a water will get caught
on a leaf and then that water evaporates
but no matter what the water no matter
what the core makeup of all of us and of
our whole planet which is water goes
back it's it's recycled hey Kim and give
us a harder question then uh what will
our with how do we all fit into the same
thing give us a harder question because
we out here you know and maybe it'll our
you know our the higher powers that be
there out there the ones just you know
they got the spigot they running that
spigot more or less and they run in that
water way hmm hmm made that captain
there that drip drip captain so alright
I'll tell you guys I'm going and I'm
nervous brah [ __ ] people are gonna laugh
at me I'm going to Nashville tonight and
I'm gonna be in a music video and it's
for a band that we all know and love
called Bishop gun so I don't know if I
should have told you guys or not cuz I
wanted to surprise you
do you know I'm not good with surprises
somebody tell me something like don't
tell anybody I'm like alright I don't
say a thing
then I turn around and I'd be like
Leonard's got epilepsy and people like
Leonard's like [ __ ] man I just told you
you said you wouldn't say nothing and
now then I'll be like I didn't say
nothing Leonard so something's wrong
with me when it comes to that sort of
thing you know sometimes like you know
if it's a sad secret or something
epilepsy I think that's just kind of a
you know your body suddenly like hey I'm
going to the [ __ ] discotheque I don't
care what you do but I think that you
know I wouldn't share something that was
really gonna really be sad or hurt
somebody's feelings
I think epilepsy we all got something
you know I'm saying I might have cardiac
arrest just kind of milling around in my
body until it's ready to strike me down
but do so yeah I'm excited and I'm
nervous
and uh I mean I'm just nervous because I
don't think of myself like as being in a
I mean look there's beauty in it because
one of the band members you know a lot
of you guys have no talked about it his
father was a friend of mine he passed
away due to alcoholism and uh you know
and I don't say that to shame him I say
that you know I love my friend and I
miss him you know but he took me in to
his home during my summers when I was in
college at Louisiana State and at Loyola
University and he took me into his home
and let me work on his farm his family
had a farm and his dad was very old and
my dad was very old and so we connected
well one of his sons was a three year
old
well now the son is in the band Bishop
Gunn and uh and so and I bet and I've
known the family for years I mean I know
Chuck I've spent the last I think you
know seven Christmas Eves at their home
and I love him you know I love the boys
you know my buddy had three sons and uh
and I love his sons you know and um you
know I love him because he can't because
he can't love him I mean he loves him
you know but he's from it he's you know
he got evaporated and he's coming back
but uh but anyway so now one of the boys
you know their band is Bishop Gunn and
there were just a music band but anyway
I'm happy because now I get to be in the
video and I know that the dad who loved
music he-man it was just every deaf
it'll give him you know he'll be doing
epilepsy in his in his grave man he'll
be thinking about us I know so that's
just fun man that's exciting and it's
just so cool like they were the bishop
gun was in Macon Georgia this week and
there was some this past weekend nurse
came out and checked it out man and that
kind of stuff
I'm just man I'm just happy to be part
of doing some cool stuff and we're gonna
do so much neat stuff dude and we're
going to do this [ __ ] together and and
I'm excited I really am
you know we had a single mom come out in
last week we might do one in Chicago
we're still putting together the piece
from last week we got some production
groups are gonna start meeting up with
us in different cities and helping us
make some of the videos better so that's
gonna be cool and dude I'm really I want
to do that gameshow with that [ __ ]
with that wrote with a cleaning woman
you know a maid a hotel maid where we
just surprised it with that gameshow so
gonna start thinking about how we can
make that out of truth but we're
definitely gonna try it I'm just worried
about you know somebody pops out of a
[ __ ] closet and it's cleaning lady
pulls out a straight shank because a lot
of these you know a lot of these Lysol
ladies been through some [ __ ] real
you know I'm saying they've been you
know they you know they know then from
Canadia you know they're not from
Connecticut they're not from you know
you you know today from some real
they're if they're from Connecticut
they're from Hartford you know I'm
saying they not from you know we you
know East Greenwich or something so I'm
just saying that there's some real
ladies but but yeah man I went to
therapy this week and what else yeah we
talked about honesty last week just
trying to get honest with myself yeah
I'm just trying to get honest for myself
oh you know sometimes it's hard for me
to just be myself fully and one thing
about anxiety is that it really it's
just such a static that prevents you
from feeling comfortable with the world
you know it's such an uncomfortable
thing mana when I really think back in a
lot of like going to clubs and that sort
of thing and just the uncomfort I would
feel but I felt this pressure like oh I
gotta be there
I gotta eventually I'll feel comfortable
and I'll seem okay and everybody will be
like oh he's okay he's fine but I just I
that never really happened I would just
be at some of these places and just be
uncomfortable and just trying my hardest
to [ __ ] look comfortable that [ __ ]
was hilarious
I like I'll hold this drink oh just my
shirt I'll put one of my hands in my
pocket I'll put two two of my hands in
my pocket I'll put my drink in my pocket
next thing know I got two drinks I got a
drink in each front pocket and I got my
hands in both of my back pockets like
I'm [ __ ] Wyatt slurp you know what
I'm saying like I look like a [ __ ]
idiot and I'm not comfortable at all but
I think I've had a lot of anxiety to in
relationships in my relationship
especially my relationship towards women
with females I've had a lot of uncomfort
or the years with the bit with that and
things that I'm just kind of realizing
like I've always needed the approval of
females constantly and I don't know
where that kind you know I know it
probably comes obviously from
relationships with Abby you know with
our mother when we're kid I get the
blanket ID you know I get them the
fabric of it I get the inner weavings of
it or I get you know I don't know how
they're all connected those weavings but
I get some of the where the different
yarns can be from from my mother from my
grandmother from me and you know from
that environment but Mae and I just
I just the approve the the I need the
approval of women I need to feel ok to
females or I mean really I need to feel
ok to myself but you know the the thing
that's how I end up feeling okay that
runs through females you know if they
see me or they recognize that I'm alive
or they acknowledge me that I'm okay and
this has been a constant thing in my
life and even when I had a girlfriend I
still you know I would need the constant
approval of other females just even in
it could be the smallest ways well I
don't want to I want to just be approval
I want to feel okay just being myself
you know I mean look I want to have a
wife and stuff one day but I want to
feel okay in the meantime just being
myself I don't know what I'm talking
about I'm just kind of wandering off on
some ideas we got a bunch of calls that
came in we'll get to some of those in
just a second I'll tell you that I got a
fly today dude I hate here's who I don't
like on the plane okay be a better air
buddy don't be this person the person
that keeps their freaking window open
when everybody else window is closed how
you gonna keep you [ __ ] window open
what are you looking at you at 30 37
you're at 37,000 feet what you peeking
around at you [ __ ] peeping air tom
you're looking at cloud tops what are
you doing you [ __ ] you trying to buy
a Care Bear what are you looking for
close your dang window because the light
is coming in and it's ruin everybody
else's experience everybody trying to
[ __ ] rest you know you got this guy
the user there's like an Asian guy he
sleeps like this he makes his own you
know you got that you know you'll have a
kind of a rubenesque kind of black lady
and she just she got on five of those
you know the sultry silky face shades
you know you got the old white guy and
here
he got it imagine you know you got a
child and they beaten a [ __ ] drum
both their pants unconscious and he
somebody gave a child a [ __ ] drum on
a plane what the [ __ ] you know when a
child gets a drum never bruh never
except when a and then when they in the
war and they got to send a little child
out there were to drum and that child is
popped off you know what I'm saying but
that's you know that's the sacrifice
that they make you know one love but you
don't ever give a child a [ __ ] drum
you idiot and then everybody trying to
get the rest even the pilots up there
rest and you know they got copilot so
they you know they rested on each other
the two of them everybody's sleeping the
cart lady she coming down he's sleeping
you know the cart guy he's he's sleeping
everybody resting and then one
[ __ ]
gotta leave their window well and that
[ __ ] ruins everybody know how to do air
travel shut your window you fricken
mutant act regular and watch your life
change for the better you know what I'm
talking about praise God man
but what was I talking about yeah I got
a fly today so you knew we had Jocko
we'll inka on a nessam man that guy's a
powerhouse he looks like he just lifts
weightlifters that's what he does for a
living dude if you looked for all the
missing people in the world they would
be in his muscles that man just I'm
surprised I don't stop them at the
border and check his muscles for uh for
illegal aliens cuz that man he got some
damn car he got some cartels on his body
I'm surprised his bones haven't filed
complaints from the wait day to have I
mean that I've never seen a man look
more like a GI Joe
and we got to talk and just you know it
was interesting and you know I feel
nervous sometimes with some of these
guests I don't want to be too I don't
want to joke around too much like Jordan
Peterson was here I can't joke around
like I can joke around some but if I
start joke drop you know really you know
mucking up you know were Yaman around
that dude's gonna get upset or he's
gonna be uncomfortable he's not gonna
want to be comfortable here and so
that's the thing you got a monitor
somebody else's comfort which is fine I
want everybody to be comfortable but um
but yeah just ma'am being around Jocko
was interesting as inspiring you know I
just cracked his book at how at home I
don't have it in front of me but I'll
bring it next time and read some of the
stuff out of it just how to begin how do
I begin that's the hardest part dude
even as being at the beach today that
first wave that first couple of [ __ ]
you know them saltwater hitters they
come in at you and that's Poseidon is
out there trying to [ __ ] lick on your
dick right when you get out in the water
you know or he's out there trying to
just you know brush his big saltwater
tongue across your teeth toss pets but
but once you get past that first lick or
something you're good you're comfortable
you start to get used to it and man the
water gets warmer the more I go in there
and I feel more comfortable oh I've
taken these you know I know how to
handle these waves this okay I can do it
is what else man well let's go to a
couple of calls you know I'll tell you
some day - not many I'm gonna tell you
one date I'm gonna tell you one date oh
we got the website open Theo von comm
slash store we got some new gang gang
get that hitter we got a couple of dopes
shirts on there and so you know that as
always the episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard on
the way to the beach you know are you
Italian you can be get that hitter let
me tell you this this right here is is
the date this is the date right here
I'll be in Chicago this weekend it's
sold out I wish I had more take
is for people and I'm sorry it is sold
out I'll be there at the Laugh Factory
September 14th and 15th I'll be at
Zanies in Nashville and I have dates in
Charlotte you can go to Thea they're
alive now as well you can go to theof on
comm / tour t oh you are and I lied and
I gave you three dates but I did a lot
actually I didn't do anything
last week we talked about if you had 96
thousand or something they had a fellow
inherited 98 thousand you know he came
upon some mom some life moments you know
where people were gonna leave him and
left into the ether and they're gonna
come back or he's gonna see them again
up in the clouds maybe that's who that
person is with their window open in the
clouds maybe it's just some lurk or up
there some heaven hunter you know
somebody's just up there hunt in heaven
close your window but let's here we had
a couple of responses of what to do with
that 98k let's hear what happened hi
this is Matthew from cenotes a South
Florida
thanks for calling Matthew onward and
last week at a caller say he had ninety
eight thousand extra dollar that he yeah
and he was calling to wonder what he
should do with that yes he was brother
he was asking for that uh he was asking
for that ah that advice them suggestions
boy them cash yes yes
you know what to do with that cash man
if I go and it the funny thing is if you
got that cash at different points in
your life yeah man if I got that cash at
about three months old I'd have a dying
borden milk truck installed in my
mother's chest first of all and I'd have
about nine extra net ballast and that's
aw italiano for me books
Nepos you ever been in nipples Florida
my and beaches are milky white but uh
you could get that on you know at
different times at two or three months
I'd have that milk installed in my
mother you know at six years old I'll
probably have a bunch of gum
I'd buy spend all my money on gum I
don't care big league chew a couple of
packs of garbage pail kids cards and
some tops
Don Russ boy get that hitter son I'd
have that ken griffey jr. rookie upper
deck let me see if you hit me at 12
years old I don't know what was going on
but I probably spend my money on hair
care you know when I was 12 years old I
used to my god dude
I'd go through half a can talk winnette
I'd go through half a camp run if I
wouldn't [ __ ] it if I didn't have half a
can of my hair I wouldn't even catch the
bus son [ __ ] it I'll learn next week
Doug I ain't leaving here without my
style and do when you spray that Aqua
Net that [ __ ] you couldn't see dude that
was a beautiful thing about Aqua Net you
should let that [ __ ] hit the air and it
would cloud you up and you could feel it
fixing your hair you know the Ock was
winning when you see it in there the net
is when it gets in there and starts
fixing just starts crab chopping up in
your follicles that's the net and then
the air we're clearing you see how you
look like oh damn this [ __ ] is a little
too MacGyver
and you did want Aqua Net again just let
it go you're like oh [ __ ]
there's some damn Burt Reynolds you know
this a little too much and then you know
Aqua Net again let that clouds disperse
any bike ah this is just right now you
got there Goldilocks and what your hair
looking beautiful but I love that Aqua
Net man anyway let's hear more what are
we talking about I don't know
Oh word so I figured you know first
thing you do pay all your debt let's
just say that's thirty thousand death
okay you got thirty thousand eight you
down a 68 grand let's see what you're
gonna do boo dad but pay all that off
you reading this fifteen thousand into
your home you know get a new roof new
HDD water all that well you got that
home spruced up why
if he says start a fire now and get that
insurance money after you got that
spruce up this is gonna be just
next-level boy this is gonna be so Reno
onward you know put about five thousand
into your cars you know get them up and
running again you know or let's get them
you know back to almost new so that
leaves you forty eight thousand X
dollars
you take $10,000 $10,000 Destin's couple
CDs take another 5,000 put up some stock
that leaves you a $33,000 still got so
you know that you know you know give a
couple thousand to your kids but in a
you know nice savings account and then
yeah without extra money I would
probably invest in some property you
know a couple acres playing a bunch of
pine trees on it after about five years
cut sell those pine trees to a company
that you know deals in wood and damn
well you tell my Christmas tree in dude
and just say it man look it and look I
want everybody if you call up here you
can say whatever you want because this
gentleman that called whoever this
gentleman is he's going a long way to
say that he wants this guy to start a
Christmas tree farm and look you don't
have to be shy around me about Christmas
buddy because I mean look there's
nothing I like more in the world than
Christmas I mean you're talking to a guy
who I sing every time I go to the
karaoke I sing uh rockin around the
Christmas tree every time think about a
time that I didn't do it you can't think
about that time because I always do it
and and so to say start a Christmas tree
falling that's beautiful
the Christmas tree should be year-round
the seasonal Christmas stuff coming I
think you should have Christmas in June
back that thing up move dad bus no I'm
saying
June 12th should be damn Christmas bruh
or little Christmas call it little
Christmas come home and we can do it I
think we can do it let's hear a little
bit more man about how you you really
want to start a Christmas tree for him
you'd only admit it yeah there you go
good money so there you go he said it
man you know put a you know get your
life tightened up get your cars
tightened up you know get your microwave
a new motor you know put a couple of
[ __ ] turbine engines in your [ __ ]
in your um hair dryer you know I'm
saying tighten you up get throat
granting a CD buy a stock if you buy a
stock the one I recommend Amazon AMZN
it's at almost 1900 right now but I
believe and I could be hella [ __ ]
wrong Russ Ann don't come back at me
like that about that cash I believe it's
gonna go to three thousand this year I
believe that let's hear more man let's
take another call what in response to
the 98 grand what should he do yo this
is rose from the City of Brotherly Love
city of brotherly love boy s West
Hollywood California
onward I'm just responding to Dillon's
voice fell about that that 98k oh yeah
he came into that buck in 98 why he came
into that flow see Bella see Verde he
feel me
he came into that flow say green pepper
pepper let's hear more on work now I'm
not a financial adviser but you know I'm
a business expert on man you know I do
know some things about finance now it
looks like Don was trying to retire some
day you know and I would recommend for
him too and that yeah everybody trying
to retire man he ain't trying to be no
sharecropper you know but let's hear
more minute thanks for calling sorry I'm
kind of antsy today and I think maybe
I'm being aggressive and maybe taking
that on some of you guys and not being
super Oh super friendly but I'm grateful
that you guys listened and and that some
people did call in about Dillon stuff
and I just got to check myself soon as I
get kind of high energy sometimes let's
hear more homeward stock market now you
know I'd recommend a mutual fund or ETF
or something that tracks the S&P 500 you
know I use Vanguard and I got the think
this total stock stock market index fund
and you know a good job you know I put
my money into it immensely got my money
and Apple Amazon all these different
companies you know all then it is you
got them hitter so he's saying there you
go put it in this a mom you know some
long-term stuff and I think long-term
stuff is a great idea the other woman
gentleman mentioned real estate I think
that's a great idea as well you know I
think also you can find a partner that
you trust which is you know or that you
do business well
you'd be a great friend but somebody you
do business well with starting an LLC
with them and you can get that way you
go half in on a property and that way um
you know it's half the risk half the
reward but it's still you're learning
how to do a property you know I I bought
a property with a friend a long time ago
and and it's been an uphill battle but
it's been it's been you know it has
gained ground and I've learned a lot
about property management over the years
and uh and it's been enjoyable man you
know it's been enjoyable during the
highs and lows it's been enjoyable but
uh but yeah there's some place you can
put 10 20 percent down and get you into
and get you into a decent spot and get
it you know a little rental investment
property going and a real investment
operate it's a long-term place to save
money really let's hear more homework
what you know this is my kisi I was
calling in regards to the dude who was
coming up on 98 grand first thing I do
is take eight grand of that you're going
a badass vacation okay he wants that
badass vacation where you gonna go do
where you trying to go
gallipoli bruh Iwo Jima dude I'm about
though I like them wore fake Hayes bruh
I'm saying I'm that dude I'll buy Assad
from Vietnam you know I'm saying I'll
buy sod from Gettysburg why didn't her a
company selling sod from famous
battlefields Kim mm second part I'll
take that ninety man I would go to uh
place like I'd were Joan somewhere like
that Edward Jones dude not the old guy
that we play for Dallas Cowboys huh and
looking through municipal bond you know
okay I think ever judged Edward Jones
paint also add too tall Jones that's who
I'm thinking of or Edward Jones brothers
dude we said that he had to do that lib
bias and he um he was always on the
swing set talking [ __ ] outside and uh
and
one day he fell off the swing set and
broke I guess broke all the bones in his
shoulder or something and his shirt
never fit the same again dude and he
would always try to make fake shoulder
he'd make fake shoulder inside of a
shirt out of like you know get him a
little piece of styrofoam or a little
couple stacks of cardboard a little
small stacks in there and just make that
[ __ ] Seaboard shoulder you know just
make that [ __ ] little the styrofoam
[ __ ] you know that Ridge baby that
upper arm [ __ ] that upper arm Ridge
you know that hard that hard turn and he
put it under his shoulder so you'd
always see him sometime and sort of look
normal and then sometime it looked like
damn he got a you know he'd have like
one of those little pints of milk under
there something carton like damn he
[ __ ] couldn't find out you know no
styrofoam or even shape his [ __ ] up at
least for church putting your shaky a
shoulder you know damn edward hello.mat
have some respect for yourself and for
the lord you out here shape up my
shipshape son ship shipshape at least
you put sexy styrofoam shoulder piece or
something you make out of some you know
a little bit of putty or some [ __ ]
River clay and keep that thing in a nice
box or a case or a little you know at
least like in a little you know uh you
know double bag it so you can break that
[ __ ] out on Sunday and stack that thing
on your broken shoulder because you
shouldn't have been swing setting look
dude when [ __ ] happens to adults and
they shouldn't be doing it children [ __ ]
boy something's wrong with you you got
their swing setting you know your
stepdaddy choked to death on a kazoo
well [ __ ] em bro
stay off that kzoo daddy you want him
saying play a man's instrument or get
out let's hear more sorry man I'm [ __ ]
damn dude I got real rural for a second
well bonds are basically loans taken out
by municipalities like if the airport
see some improvements if they don't have
the money on hand dude I ain't invest in
an airport dude some man just stole the
plane the other day man and I kind of
fell for this dude bro how much do to
that guy I'll say this the guy that
stole the plane
he seemed like a [ __ ] regular dude
who went a little bit all-in and got
caught with a few cards in his hand but
then just said well I'm going back to
heaven then it seemed like that if you
listened to the conversation you know
they're saying you know turn it around
and stop it and he's kind of worried
about others they tell him this land at
the airport he's like are you struck him
land at that airfield like is that safe
I'm like that you know he's like I don't
really know how to fly a plane I mean
it's almost like he was teaching them he
was it's interesting because he was
strategizing for his for himself and for
others at the same time man he really
seemed like he was clogged up somewhere
in his caring like his caring got
clogged up
man caring gets clogged up
you know I noticed that the last we got
couldn't man it was hard for me to care
about anybody last weekend you know it
was just hard for me to care about
anybody and um and then and and then I
went to a lot of meetings I went to some
AAA meetings this week and I'm not
trying to talk about a I'm not trying to
push anybody into that kind of stuff you
know but one thing those meetings do for
me I have to sit there and listen to
somebody else and man that's the best
thing I can do because I'm so tired of
listening to myself huh when my brain
just runs me or thinks about me in the
in the background and that kind of I
need to think about others and listening
to others in those meetings it does it
for me and then it puts me in a place
rocking care I can be a little more
caring and I hope to just keep on going
and give him you know I want to just
[ __ ] I want to just keep on you know
it feels good man you know what's funny
is I don't like being part of a group I
realized in that wild like I like it
but in my core like the inside of me
doesn't really like it I always want to
be a little separate you know always
wanna like yeah mmm somebody else's idea
like mmm I got my ID you know I gotta do
it ah you know huh well I'd rather do
you wanna mmm
you should join us in mmm there's
something about me I don't want to be a
part of a group you know
all right on
trying to think of that why would I
wonder why would I not want to be a what
about or why would it be some uncomfort
with me when it comes to being part of a
group you know I bet somewhere along the
line it attaches it with the same stuff
it's in the same fabric as why don't
like being in large groups like outdoor
to concert of that sort of thing and
that kind of thing always makes me feel
a lot of anxiety but I wonder why even
just the idea of a group or the being
you know saying oh you're part of that
that makes me feel odd or something I
don't know uh just thinking out loud
here but so there you go there's some
other opportunities municipal bonds that
gentleman said invest in the airport
let's hear a little more from that
gentleman please homeward they take out
a loan and then take that back basically
they take that off in the bank and then
the bank packages those up and sells
them out to people so they can get more
money in the pocket whoa brother st. mit
bro you know what I'm saying
onward that all 90 grand up in there
you'd be getting two fifty three hundred
dollar checks every month at least okay
no there he's saying and look at me I'm
running my mouth judging and that guy
maybe gave some good advice he's saying
municipal bonds if you put all that
90,000 into a place you might be able to
get to 250 $300 a month off that money
coming back coming in and a regular dose
get that drill you know you're dead yeah
and that's how it was for me as a baby
you know I look over across the way and
see somebody with that $90,000 top you
know I'll nipple it up sometime you'd
see a baby asleep and still [ __ ]
having milk [ __ ] brahh couldn't I had
got it dude if I wanted to get milk out
of my mom's little breasts breast bra
out of that [ __ ] pack bra I think was
just like a pectoral with a little bit
of [ __ ] drip drip in it if I wanted
to shake some real you know some real
drip drip out of my mama's PEC you know
out of the moment out of my mama's
pectoral out of my mom's you know that
pectoral then damn right had to [ __ ]
stay up there wasn't no rest and some of
them maybe just
[Music]
you're slugging down you know got milk
pooling all out of them their shoulders
all dyed beige milk beige yellow and I'm
over there just I can just beaten my
little you know I got out both hands and
both feet up on that tap you know up on
that little you know that you know my
mother had that real you know kind of
chubby pectoral shed them small hitters
you know she it was more of a chubby
pectoral and I'm just rattling the last
couple of drip traps that was made up in
net in that you know that small wide
short flat canister damn I can't even
think about my own past let's hear more
though thank you for the investment
advice and plus at the end of those
terms that are usually up to 30 years
but you get all that money back yeah
Berber 30 years what have something
happened to him in 30 years what if he
gets hit by lightning and now they got
they got his money at the airport you
know how his children gonna go over
there they didn't supposed to show up
where Delta where United and ask for
that loot Kim and most of times they
appreciate as well
yeah they appreciate you just gave him
[ __ ] $90,000 so I mean it's not a bad
idea but thirty years to get your cash
back from the government oh one other
thing I would do is if you're gonna go
to municipal bonds get them set up into
a fund or buy into a fund basically
that's something that has a bunch of
municipal bonds in together
Oh ma'am fun huh there you go more
advice and I'm not discrediting you I
appreciate your call man I'm just I
guess I'm being kind of rude today
and I'm sorry man I appreciate your call
and he say municipal bonds one of those
municipalities do default on their loan
you're not losing the farm so I think
that's a good conservative way to invest
the money sounds like he was a happy
dude already so you know why go buy a
sports car and you should like that's
just material [ __ ] man
why not have some savings for the future
and get paid a little bit each
Wow and look I just listen to the end
and that guy gave great advice and Here
I am out here [ __ ] eating these dirty
cherries I forgot to wash this sack of
them and just talking [ __ ] so I'm sorry
that's just where I'm at today I'm not
doing super great but I am doing good I
just you know I'm just being loud but
thank you for that and if you uh
there's some advice there's some I you
know there's some good stuff in there a
lot of that stuff is long-term invest
save you know maybe floss a little take
a little vacation do something fun
and plan for your future you know don't
be an unruly bastard speaking of unruly
bastards we have a board game that uh
that we're gonna be talking about from
them in the coming weeks that's pretty
dope let's take some calls man we got
some calls right here that just popped
in I haven't heard any of them so we're
gonna rifle through some of them here we
go yo what's up Bo this is Roy from San
Antonio Texas with subarray from San
Antonio man thank you thank you for
calling you know I spent a night in San
Antonio one time my car broke down I was
at a gas station out there and I watched
a bunch of people get into a fight well
I watched about four fights just over it
was over about seven hours so four
different fights it was kind of like
Bellator almost out there was like early
Bellator but like in a parking lot but I
also spent Oh actually I went there
another time and spent a night there on
the river you know down on the river
front is beautiful city beautiful people
home word let's hear more I now live in
Los Angeles
katja Shola I want to hear them cops in
the background boy hopefully this is a
you might think this is a bail bondsman
Roy might be calling that bail bondsman
that bail bonds been on accident
um let's hear more Icehouse caught your
show last night at the ice house oh yeah
thanks for coming out to that man that
was so much fun that was such a fun show
and that was last week homeward me and
my girl won and damn dogs like it was
such a cool thing to see you get up
there and the owner come out and
acknowledge you and give you that bottle
that you can't [ __ ] drink
he said he's only been up there 11 times
in the last 40 years first time you did
it was Robin Williams and the last time
you do - what's the bastion it's a
little bit [ __ ] mind-blowing bro like
me and my girl in the crowd [ __ ]
holding back tears man we were [ __ ]
we were so happy for you man so proud of
you thanks man
that's nice he to say you know it means
a lot you know this is nice because you
know what God willing to call up and say
what he feels or a thing so talk about a
moment you know I think we need more
stuff like that in the world um yeah
thanks Roy I appreciate that as sweet
and thank you for bringing your lady out
and taking you know you know invest in
some time in you and your lady going out
and having a nice evening together
you know I know that means a lot for
couples and and it's important and in a
suite that you guys did that yeah it was
kind of it was cool you know you know
it's been such a busy week man I mean I
haven't had as much time as I should
have probably to think about that the
the owner from the ice house his name is
Bob Bob Fisher and he got up there at
the end of the show and I didn't know he
was going to do this and I think we we
got some video that they sent us and
we'll see about maybe putting it up I
just want to be you know egotistical
about it but yeah he got up on stage and
he said hey here's a bottle of Dom
Perignon you know and I thought do when
I thought I thought Dom Perignon I
thought that was down syndrom in France
you know I thought it was just that you
know like a rare European disease but um
when I was young now I don't I know it
so liqueur liquor wine and so he got up
there any game of this bottle and he
said you know I've only gotten up here
11 times and the first time was Robin
Williams in the last time with Sebastian
Maniscalco and and I just want to
present you with this bottle and it was
just you know let me think about what it
was like let's hear some more your
thoughts man and and this is sweetie to
call it and think of me man I do
appreciate I remember just [ __ ]
screaming Gang Gang Gang Gang boy
you know that's cool that there you go
then that makes me feel good yeah we
need to said that that made me feel good
man yeah cuz I want to do like I'm
grateful that he came up and gave me
that you know it makes me feel good as a
person but um but I you know I'm so
tired sometimes just feeling of just I
don't know like if we if like if I just
want to be a part of something like man
this is crazy now cuz now I'm realizing
I just want to be a part of something
bigger than myself you know I just want
to be a part of like a group like I just
you know I just want to solve one now I
want us all to feel good and I want to
be you know I want to just I don't know
yeah it's like you know it's funny you
work hard to have some individual
achievement or to stand out but the only
reason I ever like try to stand out in
the first place probably was because
the only reason I tried to stand out in
the first place was because I just
wanted it
I just yeah I just wanted I probably
just wanted to be seen you know but not
be seen like oh look at me I just wanted
to feel like I was like recognize I
don't know I can't explain what I'm
trying to say maybe I just wanted to be
accepted
you know and since I didn't feel that
way then I had to stand out or I did not
stand out but act out or you know try
and get attention anyway I don't know
what I'm saying I mean I do I'm gonna
saying thank you and yeah I feel like
dude but you know if if my life dude I
hope you know I pray that I get a
million more fun stories that I can tell
you know and now you know that I can
share those with everybody and make
people feel good and that I can take
care of myself and just be you know and
help us feel good man and then I and
then you and your girl can come out and
we can all feel good you know we you
know and I feel like we got that [ __ ] we
got that [ __ ] bottle of Dom Perignon
brah you know we'll put that [ __ ] we'll
put it on the shelf when we gonna get
that next bottle you know and we'll
never a wolf I can never never drink
yeah I thought about that too this dude
gave me a bottle of liquor I'm like hey
let's do my room my whole career if I
take this bottle out back but yeah man
that's you know I'm just happy to take
one for the team I'm just happy to be up
there in the batter's box on that day in
that moment and uh and maybe the next
day you went to work Roy and you had you
had to do something in your work and you
had to like um you had to step up and do
something for a few minutes or or you
had to take the lead or you had to be a
man the next day and uh and you just
feel good about that because you know
every time we man up and every time we
you know we you know we do something
good you know we win one for all of us
bro and so that's what I'm trying to say
I guess I'm glad you were there dude
because that makes it mean something you
know that we are able to do some of this
[ __ ] together but it was yeah it was
nice you know
it's hard for me to accept I guess
you
it's hard for me to accept if somebody's
nice not nice but I don't know man you
guys got me thinking today but let's
hear the rest of your call man an
excitement bro it was just so it was
unreal man it was like watching like my
big brother
get acknowledged for something or like
one of my best friends I listen to you
all the time I worked I came my shitty
little nine-to-five you helped me get
through that [ __ ] so and I mean I'm
telling everybody Dawg like yo feels the
next [ __ ] big thing man it's the next
big big comedian man like I know it dude
I see a lot of things coming for you and
last night that's just [ __ ]
that's they just like made it real I
know I was right now but congratulations
and that [ __ ] was super cool super cool
to see of super cool to meet you and I'm
just happy for you man congratulations
thanks bro Gang Gang dude right at you
right now man Gang Gang bruh yeah it
makes me feel good that
that you think I'm okay because it's
weird it's like if you think I'm okay
then I'll think I'm okay
you know like somehow some of that stuff
got a little mixed up I guess when I was
young but I'm grateful dude and I
appreciate it I'm glad you and your girl
have fun dude that's you know man it's
so funny like I used to get on stage and
be so angry all the time and like I just
wanted to like like I just wanted to
make people like like it used to be much
more like I wanted people to like look
at you know look at me like I like I'm
worth like I'm worthwhile you know like
I'm doing my job I'm worthwhile you know
like I'm not worthless you know like
that's what I'm saying I'm not worthless
but now I get up there and I feel like
like I just want to do well so that I
can make us I can make people feel I
don't know I I don't know man I got I'm
not trying to make anybody do anything I
know that I don't have any I just I
don't know but I think you call him
whatever it is that you call and say
manage it make me feel yeah man like
like we like yeah like I'm doing this
because I want you guys to feel good you
know like I love telling stories and
like you know I want to make people
laugh one day I want to make people
laugh in other countries I want to make
you know I just want to make people
laugh you know cuz it makes people feel
good the fact that you and your
girlfriend came out and had a nice time
together you know and like we didn't
have to do anything [ __ ] up and we
didn't have to do any draw you know like
we just were able to have fun you know
and I don't care that I'll you know that
I'm the one saying most of the words and
you got to do the laugh and like we each
got to do our part you know something I
don't you know it's hard for me to laugh
sometimes so maybe that's why you know I
took the other side of the net sometimes
and there will come a time where you'll
do a job and I'll need you know and I'll
be there and I don't know I'm just
[ __ ] happy to be a part of something
homeward
take another call here I feel my name's
Tara and
whatup Tara I'm just here recovering had
my arm amputated earlier - damn yeah
your arm amputated [ __ ] that's crazy
that's crazy I'm so I'm sorry to hear
that I'm sorry
god I'm so weird oddly checked out right
this not checked out but I'm just my
shame my thoughts can be a little
disjointed at times but disjointed you
wrote that one so I just had what am i
man I need I am like just roasting it
this I'm sorry
look I've never had never I'm eating
these cherries I got to get my life
together I am sorry that while you lost
your arm your arm is gone your arm is
gone today and you feeling somewhat
disjointed let's hear more about this
coming off the anesthesia well I'm very
sorry I'd have that experience I can
only imagine how scary this is right now
you know like I woke up one time and one
of my legs got caught into my shorts
somehow I was sleeping and my foot got
caught up in my shorts on my leg look
like more just like a knee you know and
I thought something happened to me and
one time I got extremely high on cocaine
and got locked in this house not locked
in but just inside and thought
everything was locked because I was you
know you do enough cocaine and suddenly
like all but you know you just believe
that locks are everywhere and I uh and I
met a woman this is off tender and we
she didn't have and she had lost her
legs I don't know why I'm telling you
that stuff homework um and they say my
arm it was actually my hand it was just
a little bit of the arm and the reason
why I had to do that is because last
year I got run over by a train Oh
oh I'm so sorry I'm so sorry to hear
this and I'm so sorry that I was kind of
joking around in the beginning yeah man
this is a lot this is a lot to be run
over by a train let's hear more because
well that's sort of a long story
um so the fluence that happened I was
like super stoked on my offense like
getting back to good things but my arm
is just not really worth saving it's
kind of a lost cause
so I'm oh I'm sorry to hear that you
know if I had an external um I you know
I would let you have my arm or if I even
had a small leg you know that could do
do something cool you know or hold stuff
I would let you have that and I'm sorry
that you're having to deal with this and
I appreciate you sharing this moment
with us letting that go and then trying
to UM get a prosthetic so I can go back
to Ray um I actually have my degree in
and learned how to do which is
acupuncture and Chinese medicine so I
just done one has this really nice story
and I love your show you're listening to
you on the way home from the hospital
and believe it or not this is an
outpatient surgery Wow
that's outpatient oh my gosh I mean it I
mean I'm just learning so much like
right here in this moment
um and I'm sure a lot of the listeners
aren't I you know and I appreciate you I
appreciate you you know you're really
really brave to go in there you know and
get part of your arm and not have part
of your arm whenever you leave there you
know I've left a lot of stuff I like
I've you know I've lost I've left tons
of [ __ ] different places but I've never
you know I've never left a place and not
had all of me with me you know and so
that's
you know I've left just regular stuff
that everybody leaves that I've never
left you know not been able to have my
whole body with me
homeward thanks for listening take care
well I'm so sorry
you know if I uh if you need me to hug
somebody for you let me know and I'll be
your hug hit man you know and I'll go
out there and I'll hug them you know if
you feel like I don't know you know if
your impairment is gonna have you you
know your hugs not working as well but
I'll be able to hug somebody for y'all
hug the [ __ ] out of somebody you want
somebody hug you want to show up at
Christmas and just drop nine of them in
a row across a whole group of family
members that come in the door at once
I'll do it I'll be it I'll drop some
hugs for you you know and I wish I were
here right now I give you a big one
it's really brave I mean I'm sorry to
hear about your experience and I wonder
what its gonna how this is gonna play
out in your life in like a positive way
you know to go and then want to still
help people with herbal medicine and and
that sort of thing that's pretty
incredible you know you still have a
desire to help and I bet you'll probably
be able to do have really interesting
information for people that have an
amputation or uh you know or missing
part of themselves you know how what
what is that Chinese medicine like how
is that for them that could be really
interesting I think I'm not sure where
you live that maybe you can hit the
hotline as well and let us know where
you live you might be interesting just
to talk to somebody that is an amputee
and I'm so I'm sorry if I'm not using
the correct terms but that is an amputee
and to see what that's like you know and
just to get an idea what some of that is
like and they had to do by us when I was
growing up and they said he was missing
his head you'd always hear about him you
know and they called him head Ronald
this boy head Ronald and uh and nobody
ever saw I never saw him and so I guess
it was just a lie you know but but I'm
so sorry that you're having to deal
with that and and yeah I'll check in
with the Ummah see I'm a hitch up just
through the hotline I got your number
and just check in with you we got a lot
more calls that came in but I can't get
to any more right now because I have to
go to the airport literally my flight
leaves in one hour and 34 minutes and I
am and I got to be on my way I do want
to play this song there one more time on
the way out and that's it
you know I know today was all over the
place and sometimes it is and sometimes
it is and then I'm not apologizing [ __ ]
it that's where I am right now that's
where I am today I don't know
my back hurts a little bit you know I
got I got let me see 23 hours of no
masturbation so that's kind of where I'm
riding that you know I got a low tank my
tank is low but I'm hoping to G up and G
out who needs a Red Bull baby G up you
know least have a baby sitter we're
coming in and like who needs a red bow
jeah baby look we can't [ __ ] drink
red Bull dude we're eight but praise God
raw all right I'm gonna take you guys
out with a little bit of more of this
this gentleman right here mr. Evan
Bartles um hit the hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
and let us know what's going on you know
it's uh it is it's you can be a part of
the show you know you can be a part of
the show and we'd love to have you be
part of the show so just hit that
hotline and let us know let us know
what's going on and see what we see if
we can you know just just be here
together thank you to everybody that did
come out at ice house and that was a
special night and it was a special
moment and I'm sorry to anybody I you
know I got frustrated at the Comedy
Store I was [ __ ] angry and the reason
why was the air conditioned wasn't on in
the joint and so they got people in
there all hot it up trying to laugh I
all [ __ ] hot it up in that thing
people bacon out and trying to giggle
you can't [ __ ] him
you can't just be festering in the heat
and giggling [ __ ] ain't funny so
but but I'll see you guys man big tits
or small tits whatever you were raised
on that's okay
I'm gonna come up with some more ideas
where anxiety could have come from doggy
style babies you know them DSBs boy you
know that there ain't a anxious ridden
and you can't shake that doggy style
conception anxiety you can't shake that
doggy style conception anxiety but I
know that I'm out here and I know that
I'm part of a battle that goes on every
day in every moment and I know I want to
be a part of the solution and I know
that I'm a [ __ ] along the way and I'm
you know we're all out here we just you
know you know we're [ __ ] up dude we're
[ __ ] up but we're here together so we
can we can be curious about it you know
and that's pretty that's pretty cool I
think thank you to everybody they called
you guys be good to yourselves
you'll probably deserve it you probably
deserve it I know you do and I'm gonna
take us out right here with Evan Bartle
the devil God and me
[Music]
you
mother may open my this is a great big
world waiting right outside mother
marries my boy we the people have that
Choi mother is my head go I did not try
this hmm it's powerful mother may I
sleep though I did not invite you guys
take care of me I love y'all
oh you can come for me
[Music]
[Laughter]
you can't comfort me